what i'm going to actually go through
with you is um a couple of concepts that
relate to this exercise that you're
currently doing
and something you're going to say mr wu
why didn't you show me this earlier and
the answer is well i actually wanted you
to do it by hand before i showed you the
technology way to do it that's the first
reason the second reason is this is not
the last time you're going to need to do
this so this skill i'm about to teach
you you may be already past this in the
exercise you're like oh i don't need it
today but you will need it later on okay
so if you have an open desmos already
please do that and what i'd like you to
have next to that is
if i'm not mistaken in exercise 9d
question 3 has a bunch of data sets that
they provide to you and i ask you to do
every second letter because i know it is
laborious to do this by hand i mean if
you have done that your effort was not
wasted you'll see why in a second but
what i'm going to show you right now is
how to not do that by hand because
obviously we often deal with data sets
that are impractically large to deal
with and that's what we have technology
to help us with okay
now some of you may not be aware and
that's why i'm going to show you you can
use desmos in much the same way as you
can use excel to put a graph which has
plotted points on there for you okay so
what i'd like you to do is over here in
the top left hand corner just to make
sure i've made this big enough and i
have
if you hit that plus icon you almost
never do this you just start typing
right but if you hit that plus i icon a
menu comes up and you'll see one of the
options says table see that one go ahead
and hit it for me
and what it will offer to you is the
option to put down coordinates
essentially which is what the question
has provided to you a set of cartesian
coordinates x's and y's so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to put in the
values here and as you type them in much
like with your calculator when you're
putting in single variable with
frequency or double variable it goes
down the column rather than across so
what's the way i'm going to do this
the coordinates are 0 3 1 2 2 4 etc
right so i'm going to go 0 press enter
and it goes down to the next x
coordinate so on your textbook i'm
reading all the x coordinates as i go
along the list does that make sense so i
want you to follow with me as you do
this i think the next one is 1 and then
2 3 4
5 six you can see if you just hit enter
it just goes up by one because it
notices that's what you're probably
doing but then the next one is not seven
it's not even eight even though it puts
in seven automatically for you if i'm
not mistaken it's a nine is that right
did i get that right it's a nine right
yep so i've put in nine there so there's
all my x's
and then i go over and do the same thing
with the y's and i'm gonna ask you to
cross-check this for me because i'm just
doing off my own tiny little screen i
think it's a three
two four
three
two fives and two sevens
did i get that right am i reading it
properly
because you guys are yep okay happy
right
so what you can see now is desmos has
just sort of popped all of those points
on for you you can just like zoom in and
out and do whatever you like okay now
this is nice to see the data very
quickly you can see obviously rather
than doing this by hand or so much
faster right but actually there's
something even more useful we can do
here which is i think they ask you to do
a rough line of best fit by eye right
okay now just
pins down and lapsed damage for a second
because something i want to highlight
for you that's really important
there is a classic wrong way to do a
line of best fit which often comes up
like you get asked like how to do a line
of best fit and students will often do
this and it's a thing that's known not
to do so you guys know in multiple
choice questions you got like an abcd
right what i'm about to show you is
often what we call a distractor it's a
like plausible looking option that's
deliberately wrong we put it in there
because we know a lot of people will
pick it even though it's incorrect let
me see if i can do this for you just by
doing it on the screenshot
a very common way to do a line of best
fit is to say well let's just start
where the data starts and end where the
data ends right so it will look
something like i wonder if will this
work let me see here we go it will look
something like this
you put your rule up there it starts at
the first odd point and it ends at the
last data point so you can put you know
a line across there and say oh look look
at my straight line that looks pretty
good right and then you say okay i'm um
i'm finished right now it doesn't look
bad like you could do worse than this
couldn't you right it's not bad as a
line of best fit however there's a
massive problem with it right if i start
at the beginning and end at the end
what might create for me a terrible line
of best fit
anyone to give me a thought
yeah daniel what do you reckon
if your first
and last data points on which you are
relying to do this happen to be outliers
like suppose we happen to have a data
point up here maybe that was my startup
right well your line of best fit is
useless now isn't it okay now in this
case it's like not too bad so we kind of
got lucky okay but i can guarantee you
if you are provided with a data set and
you draw a line of best fit from the
first starter point to the last one
they'll say no that's not a line of best
fear they'll deliberately craft the data
so that will give you a bad line of best
fit so you're like well that's a common
error okay so that's the first thing
let's get rid of that i don't need it
anymore
so how do we do a good line of best fit
well
even though you're only asked to do an
informal one i'm going to help you do
kind of like a not perfect but like a
better than informal one okay we are not
going to go through the beginning or the
end but there is actually a single data
point that's very important that you're
going to help me calculate that the line
of best fit is always supposed to go
through it's not the beginning
it's not the end
it's right there in the middle now it's
not exactly the middle it's not the
median but it's the mean okay you've got
a bunch of x values and you've also got
a bunch of y values i'd like you to help
me work out what is the average of all
the x values you can see there's zero
one two three four five six nine there
are eight x values so you're gonna add
them up divide by eight
and then maybe at your table someone
else on the table can you work out your
average for your y
uh
data points
get me an x get me a y
and then once you've got that
you can tell me and then we're all going
to plot it so can i get a show of hands
who's gotten to the x
mean we've got one i want to wait for a
cup two three
okay boss what do you got
3.75 that's what i calculated as well so
there's an x average and a y average now
thank you very much matthew 4.5 now if
you just go ahead and type in
coordinates just like you normally would
they will give you a point and just
because like it's probably given you a
different color because desmos will just
cycle through the colors but just to
make it really obvious let's call this
the mean so just tick the label box and
it's there as mean it's not an actual
data point okay so go ahead and put this
on
now i said that the line of best fit is
actually supposed to go through that
point so i want to now draw like i want
to sort of put my ruler against this and
sort of move it around right now what's
great is you know enough coordinate
geometry to know the exact equation of
every line
that goes through that point let me say
that one more time
you know the form
of the equation of the lines that go
through that point you don't know what
the gradient is but you know the point
that it goes through which form of a
straight line are you going to use
this is actually why we teach you them
that's why they're useful
you don't know the gradient
but you do know the point
what's the form of a line that has those
two
it's point gradient form right we know
the point we're going to modify the
gradient so it fits as best as we can so
from memory
point gradient form is y minus y1 equals
m
outside of x minus x1 right well there's
your x1 and your y1 right there so let's
go ahead and say y minus y1 in this case
is 4.5
it equals now i don't know the gradient
the whole point is like i've got to try
and put my ruler up against the page
we've got something better on the ruler
we've got desmos right that gradient is
unknown so i'm just going to call it m
and then here comes x minus and the x
one you told me was three point seven
five okay now as usual desmoses prompted
you he's like do you want to add a
slider for m it's like yeah we do okay
now before we fiddle with it right it
defaults to one
the slider defaults to go from negative
10 to 10. now just to make it easier for
us i'm going to change that range so if
you go to this cog the wheel up here
right and say edit you can see you can
provide a range for m right we can put a
lower bound and an upper bound now i'd
love you guys to tell me what might be
reasonable numbers to choose
for our upper and lower bounds let's
think about lower bound first negative
tens silly why is negative 10 never
going to be the gradient of my line of
best fit daniel
correlation this is obviously going
upwards right it's trending upwards so
negative 10 is silly negative five
actually nothing negative makes sense so
i'm going to go ahead and put a 0 there
right on my lower boundary
now for my upper boundary
well you can see 1 actually doesn't do
too bad a job does it right but i don't
know if it's best maybe i want something
a little bit steeper than that so i'm
going to go ahead and put 2
as my sort of upper bound there and i
think that's quite reasonable okay
so now what we can do is we can with a
bit more finesse and control we can move
where that is and we can say well which
do you think is best right
it's not a bad way to say like i roughly
want the same number of points above the
line as below that's not always best but
that's not too bad see how i've got four
above and four below okay and you can
keep on fiddling with that i mean if i
went past there you'd probably say oh
like i'm i'm fitting
these data points pretty well but this
last one over here i've kind of missed
that one does that make sense so you
feel with that what value do you end up
with what value are you happy with
what do you think
0.6 or so
bit on the higher end it starts to get a
bit like iffy right but does that
roughly make sense
okay i'm pretty happy with that so i
just want you to note you can use
technology for plotting these points
it's often very helpful especially when
you've got a lot of data points and then
when you're doing this line of best fit
well this is a much better way than just
like whacking your ruler on there and
just getting it roughly okay with that